[Background voices]
YO YO MA >> Hello, YouTube. I'm Yo yo Ma,
and so my answer is work hard and be loving.
And by that I mean-ah-be empathetic to people,
be nice to people, practice empathy.
Um-how do you do that? Well, I think you actually
have to be able to be able to have the imagination
to be in someone else's shoes. So, you know,
just walk around and say, "So-and-so, what's
their life like?"
And-ah-and-and you have to do that without
pre-judgment. You actually have to be there
and not say, "Oh, well that's a horrible way
to be!" No, you actually have to be them from
inside looking at the world from their point
of view.
And I think that's-that's actually a harder
thing to do than-um-than__.
Anyway, I think-um-enjoy! Bye.